good morning john i am often tempted to
make videos about whatever is most
frustrating to me at the moment when i'm
about to make a video and that is a bad
impulse it's kind of selfish because one
it isn't really focusing on what's like
most broken about the world just on what
annoys me the most but also the thing
that's annoying me is also very likely
to just be something that also annoys
you it's not like there's a bunch of
people out in nerdfighteria who have
like really deep disagreements with me
about vaccines for example like i asked
on twitter if people who could get
vaccinated have been vaccinated and like
nerdfighteria is the most vaccinated
state in america so it's selfish because
it's more me talking about my own gripes
than what's actually broken about the
world and it's not impactful because i'm
just griping to people who agree with me
there's an even more important reason
not to do it and i don't think i would
have realized that if it hadn't been
yesterday this week with all of the
lovely things that happened around that
which reminded me what is so remarkable
about this community nerdfighteria is
the community that launched a thousand
projects it is an extremely productive
place we have together made some really
amazing things but importantly there
have also been projects that have gone
nowhere like back in the day i wanted to
start an organization called read it
first which encouraged people to read
the book before they watched the movie
or the tv show but then a bunch of
people inside this community were like
hank why are you trying to control how
someone enjoys their stuff and initially
i pushed back against that because
that's what you do when somebody finds a
reason why your idea might not be good
but eventually i realized i mean yeah
like that's pretty counter to the vibe
but the things that have vibed whether
they're
huge now like crash course or they've
really helped creators make a living
like dftba records or they're just
shockingly impactful like the awesome
socks club that has now raised over six
hundred thousand dollars for partners in
health those things are no longer
nerdfighter projects they are having
impacts way outside of us because of us
john we've worked on projects that are
by any measure much bigger than this
community crash course has four times
more subscribers than vlogbrothers it
reaches way more people than this
channel and it has a big impact on the
people it reaches it is by any measure a
bigger deal than vlogbrothers but it is
not a bigger deal to me this is the core
of what we do and also of course without
it crash course would absolutely not
exist now i don't want to pretend like
none of this is weird this is absolutely
weird we didn't know what we were doing
when we started we still kind of don't
know what we're doing now this isn't a
thing that you can go to school to learn
and i think everybody here understands
that like we're not trying to be perfect
like the idea of being perfect
makes me nauseated i can't like i don't
know how to do it i don't even know how
to think about what it might be we are
trying to enjoy things together learn
together and do positive and impactful
things together because there is so much
value in a constructive community that
shares values and communities like that
just don't feel common these days like
one of my most successful videos is like
my like 26 rants video where i just like
yell about stuff but i never did another
one of those and not because i'm not
annoyed by stuff whereas i did do a
bunch of dad joke videos and now do a
dad joke at the beginning of every dear
hank and john because like that's
that's the vibe i think it's very
important to be in groups of people that
are based on common enjoyment and
appreciation and also like mutual
accomplishment and i'm really glad that
i am a part of some of those communities
including most importantly this one it's
not simple it's never going to be
perfect nobody ever gets everything
exactly right but one of the foundations
of this place i think is not to focus on
what is making us most frustrated or
annoyed or powerless but instead to
focus on what we can do with what we
have and i'm excited to keep doing that
with you john i'll see you on tuesday